mais lorsqu'on va sur facebook alors le
facebook notamment des redifs matin il
ya toujours des vidéos qui sont très
très très populaire et ce sont les
vidéos scientifique
alors vous savez 2018 est derrière nous
avons maintenant regarder voir ce que
2019 va nous réserver alors sur la
question de la science et on s'est donc
ça intéresse beaucoup beaucoup de
personnes et la mer personne pour nous
parler de ça évidemment c'est renaud
manuguerra gagner vous le connaissez
très bien qu'ils journaliste
scientifique bons journaux bonjour merci
pour l'introduction mais vraiment il ya
un intérêt particulier on sort
actuellement le port pour la science
renault avant de commencer actuellement
il ya un événement scientifique est
extrêmement important a parlé d'ailleurs
ya c'est cette fameuse on your eyes in
qui est en train de survoler un
astéroïde ça ça fait à peine quelques
heures que l'année commence et on a déjà
brisé un nouveau record donc c'est pour
la première fois on a visité un objet
qui était la limite de notre système
solaire c'est un astéroïde qui s'appelle
ultimate ou les qui fait environ 35 km
de diamètre et qui à 6.6 milliards de km
de la terre et c'est vraiment ça c'est
la sonde de la nasa new rising qui a
réalisé l'exploit c'est celle qui est
devenue populaire elle qui donne une
célèbre 2015 après avoir fait le survol
de pluton plan renvoyer toutes ces
photos là donc c'est vrai minutes 33
environ jeu juste après le décompte que
la sonde est passé à 14 km par seconde à
côté du petit matou littell a pris un
maximum de photos possibles de ce goût
de ce rocher là qui serait qui grosso
modo l'équivalent d'un délit briques
fondamentales du système solaire c'est
pour ça que c'est important également de
l'étudier de l'avoir la photographier la
cartographier ouais c'est exactement ça
c'est comme si on voit on retourner dans
un avenir très dans un lointain passé
qu'on prenait des photos de cette roche
là parce que c'est les chercheurs
pensent que c'est un objet qui restait
vraiment inchangé depuis les débuts du
système solaire il ya 4,5 milliards
d'années
et là ça prend six heures de
transmission de transmettre
l'information entre la sonde et la terre
donc on devrait avoir les premières
images en basse résolution d'ici la fin
de la journée mais ça va prendre jusqu'à
20 mois avant que la sonde transfère
toute l'information du saut vol de cette
nuit on va voir les images davantage
brut a cessé durant la journée
effectivement c'est un peu plus tard
d'ailleurs c'est aux québécois je crois
qu'ils actionnent vous savez là sont
dans la panade et celui envoyé ces
dernières commandes hier c'est cet
intéressant
une autre sonde aussi d'autres sont dans
l'année qui va aussi capté notre
attention notamment une sonde chinoise
oui c'est ça d'ici quelques jours la
chine va poser une première sonde sur la
face cachée de la lune que ce qui est
des endroits qui ne sont connais
beaucoup la lune c'est la face cachée
tout endroit qu'on n'a jamais explorées
avant donc c'est la sanch angie 4 qui a
quitté que décollé de la terre le 8
décembre dernier
ça a pris cinq jours avant de se
retrouver en orbite autour de la lune
mais depuis ce temps là elle est comme
rester en place c'est pas encore posé la
surface les chercheurs attendent le
meilleur moment pour faire cette
alunissage probablement un moment où est
ce que le soleil va éclairer la face
cachée de la lune peut savoir faciliter
les opérations et aussi aider les
batteries de la son qui va se promener à
terre en alimentant ces panneaux
solaires donc s'ils réussissent ce sera
non seulement une peut découvrir une
première scientifique vraiment
importante
mais ce sera aussi une façon pour la
chine de montrer qu'elle est une
superpuissance à l'égal des états unis
et donc on l'a vu d'ailleurs date ahmad
en possession du haut de son os qui vont
vous intéressé durant l'année oui c'est
sûr cette année il ya beaucoup de sondes
qui ont décollé en 2018 qui vont nous
envoyer de l'information en 2019 sas et
c'est quelque chose d'assez intéressant
notamment celles en orbite autour du
soleil la sonde la parker sur le
problème est assez intéressante
ils sont revient sur la taille un
élément qui va rester dans l'actualité
scientifique et les changements
climatiques on parle vous savez de plus
en plus des changements climatiques
alors c'est aussi donc ce serait
intéressant d'humanisme il va y avoir
beaucoup d'études qui vont se faire qui
vont intéresser les chercheurs notamment
au niveau de l'antarctique et plusieurs
études qui vont se faire plusieurs
chercheurs qui vont aller voir
l'évolution des glaces au pôle sud de
voir le rythme avec lequel elle fonde tu
commences à influencer les modèles
climatiques
mais un élément nouveau qui va arriver
en 2019 ça concerne ce qu'on appelle la
géo-ingénierie ceci l'idée un peu
controversé qu'on est capable de changer
le climat de façon contrôlée
il ya des chercheurs qui croient que vu
qu'on est incapable de maîtriser nos
émissions de gaz à effet de serre mais
le seul moyen d'éviter les pires
conséquences des changements climatiques
c'est de diminuer artificiellement la
température de la terre et la méthode
dont on parle le plus ça consiste à
répandre certaines particules dans la
haute atmosphère de la terre pour
qu'elle reflète une partie des rayons du
soleil puis ça empêche de réchauffer la
terre un problème par contre avec la
géo-ingénierie c'est que beaucoup de
personnes qui s'inquiètent que ça
s'empire la situation donc enfin
dans des choses qui en démarrant des
processus qu'on maîtrise pas
complètement puis conseiller on sache
pas exactement parce que ça s'envoie con
qu'on joue peu à l'apprenti sorcier dans
le fond donc en 2019 ya des chercheurs
de l'université harvard qui vont faire
une première expérience de
géo-ingénierie extrêmement restreinte
juste pour voir les effets et les
conséquences de ce système là par contre
peu importe les résultats qui vont
obtenir ça changera pas que c'est pas
une solution miracle il va vraiment
falloir qu'on apprenne à réduire nos
émissions si on veut éviter le pire et
en terminant aussi arnaud évidemment on
a parlé beaucoup de la légalisation du
cannabis alors ça risque également
d'exploser tout ce domaine de recherche
oui parce que jusqu'en 2018 c'était très
difficile de faire des études sur des
drogues comme le cannabis
partout dans le monde surtout dans les
pays qu'ils contrôlent comme les etats
unis c'est pour ça d'ailleurs qu'on a
encore la difficulté à savoir c'est quoi
les effets positifs ou négatifs du
cannabis pour la santé mais si on
connaît la plante depuis très longtemps
mais avec la légalisation en eux aussi
une hausse importante de l'aide du
financement de la recherche sur le
cannabis pieuse c'est sur ces drogues
donc on peut s'attendre non seulement de
hausse de nos connaissances sur les
propriétés médicinales du cannabis mais
aussi un regain d'intérêt sur d'autres
drogues qui pourrait avoir des effets
bénéfiques pour la santé une des plus
sains qui suscite plus d'intérêt en ce
moment c'est les agents psychédélique
par exemple on parle du champignon
magique la composante active qui
s'appelle appcity aussi bine bl elle est
connue pour avoir bay à déchets des
études ont suggéré qu'il pouvait avoir
des effets vraiment important sur pour
pollet pour les dépressions majeures
donc pour diminuer les effets des
dépressions agents qu'on veut pas
réduire autrement sans avoir des effets
sur la dépendance ni des risques de
surdose mortelle donc en 2019 on va
avoir les premiers résultats des
premières grandes études qui ont été
faites sur ces sujets là ça devrait
susciter beaucoup l'attention peuvent
être donnés le domaine là était un champ
médical et installa c'est toujours été
ça merci beaucoup rediffusés plusieurs
plusieurs sujets que vous allez
évidemment regarder on va en parler
cette année fait bonne année à vous
aussi